schivato il mondo schivato volevo fare
un'entrata scenica pros è spenta la luce
mi sono preso un infarto e così tanto
stava venendo una merda quindi va bene
lo stesso pelle tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo video sarò fa vigente
oggi siamo tornati dopo una vita e mezza
su amy di wall street lei che presto
ragazzi non ho finito nell'uomo arrivati
all'ultima ora l'ultima finita questa
dovrei aver finito il gioco il problema
è che finire questo ora è abbastanza
difficile cioè non so se l'avete montato
me l'avete chiesto in cinese di finirlo
visto che ancora non avevo finito perché
mi manca ancora questo grazie da port
grassi mille della mia sto fermo sono
fermo sono fermo sono fermi perché stavo
dicendo ragazzi che dall'ultima volta
che ho provato a giocarlo
siamo arrivati all'ultima ora quindi
questa qua dopo questa in teoria dovrei
aver finito in teoria perché siamo
arrivati al 5 di notte manca non sono
poi le 6 del mattino sarebbe l'orario in
cui dovrei uscire di casa
quindi devo resistere praticamente solo
quest ora so tutto un episodio per farlo
prego iddio di riuscirci tanzarella
la cosa che io che ho visto in particol
tratto si è chiusa la porta ma non me ne
frega un cazzo perché tanto ormai
la roja bastarda pensava non mi
prendesse mai era uscito ma come ai
ragazzi la partenza da dio come pertanto
la immaginavo e mi stavo dicendo ragazzi
che nel mentre ho visto un sacco di
video di amy di uno stupro e ho scoperto
che ci fu un sotterraneo in realtà so
come ci si arriva solo che non ti devi
fare i cazzi tuoi
ok i cazzi tuoi la gonnellina che c'hai
te la devi prendere tallinn
lo sai cosa devi fare allora perchè non
lo fai il problema è che se ci vado non
so perché
e vabbè che palle ok che culo se vado
nel sotterraneo non chiedetemi perché ma
la tizia mi uccide cioè non in teoria
gli altri vedo che via sala viaggiano
tranquillamente nel sotterraneo
io no non so perché sono qui sono
mordente antoni piglia
mi sono mosso mi piglia per forza sarà
andato non so come sia possibile mi sono
mosso di brutto come ha fatto ad
andarsene
eccola l'ho trovata perfetto non ha una
tranquilla non ti disturbo se sei al
cesso non approvavano chiudi che quando
mi mandi messaggi adesso [ __ ]
delle moneta che ho aperto la porta ma
non mi sono mosso
no mi sono fatto [ __ ] chi è che mi
chiama chi ti ammazzo la madre io lo
capisco che sei brutta e ti devi
coprirla faccia anch'io su brutto però
me ne faccio una ragione vivo che cazzo
fai
c'è gente che qua sotto ci va
tranquillamente
io non posso andarci poco non ci posso
stare ho capito non è un problema non ci
torno più devi morire di crepacuore
tranquillo abbiamo finito phinet
freddy's finiremo anche questo grazie
dove come da dove si è puntato
spiegamelo non sei stata tu vero non è
stata lei ragazzi ma anche al 40 secondi
ok quali deve moriarty la famiglia sotto
un camion sotto un treno sotto il pene
di rocco siffredi sotto quello che vuoi
per chi deve morire se sei sparita ne
devi andare proprio non è che devi
puntarmi un secondo dopo se sei
sfarinati sparita mentre agazzi è
impossibile non ce la farò mai ve lo
dico a prescindere impossibile
non posso spostare io la lancetta che
fastidio davis puntare sempre non quando
ci hai voglia li mortacci tua
sofia non ho schivato il mondo schivato
che cazzo ma che cazzo libico ed
efficiente ed efficiente a caso come ma
l'avete 9 sarete vista tutti così
successo anche tu però devi farti una
vita a 0 meno male che lo documentata se
non ci credeva nessuno quando superi una
stanza con quel tipo non dovrebbe più
seguirti quindi non doveva seguirmi
dentro la stanza da letto mi ha seguito
lo stesso e si è fermato un millimetro
prima come è possibile come quando la
trovi sei tu veux stampa o minchia
un'ora e mezza per trovarti deficiente
quando trovo la famiglia con lame
capelli bianchi che sta di là si è
chiusa la porta fra terzo ok va bene
avessimo tocco dai partiti fatto fermo
sono fermo sono fermo sono fermo sono
fermo un secondo fa mi hai rotto il
camuno ma ok mo di nuovo è meno male e
l'ho trovata che colora nel corridoio
sì sì sì che culo
incredibile beh va beh devo resistere
ragazzi so dov'è fotte sega pasta che
resistono agli altri non devo
assolutamente sbagliare perché l'ho
trovata dunque anche brutto dove
esistenti
ero fermo
ero fermo no ragazzi europee ero fermo
però dai christian t lo so che non lo
finire un maestro gioco inutile che
orcaella è devi morire e devi morire
male la tua ombra come fa essere più
alta di te spiega ma com'è possibile
questa cosa sai che palle o la porta in
forza quanto su quanto mi dispiace no
non mi spiace non posso dove cazzo è era
qua ra qua prima era lì prima dove è
sparita noise paritaria e non è poco non
è colpa mia se sei sparita se
funzionasse come deve funzionare che
quella cristiana sta ferma lì e quel
[ __ ] non mi salta addosso se sto
fermo avrei vinto adesso non la trovo
romario che sono già passato ovunque
anno ecco porca [ __ ] che perché
colpo presso metti in ugazzi di cartello
con diritto di precedenza non lo so ma è
successo non si guardano le donne mentre
fanno la pipì fatica situa e vai via
note etico per gli occhi non si è
scusata sono entro anch'io nello
spogliatoio delle donne così è a scusate
ma sto guardando tutti gli utenti e ti
devo importunare mentre stai pisciando
perdonami però se nomi in gruppo hanno
tutti ok ok nel cesso abbiamo detto che
c'è non c'è non c'era nessuna parte non
c'è qui non c'è lì non equa non è nella
sala vedete stava scherzando bye bye bye
bye bye bye bye bye bye
cioè ho fatto a pirata forse siamo a
metà ragazzi però so già che non andrò
più avanti così non usciamo milano
molto breve allegria anche obama
va bè ragazzi ci ho provato in tutti i
sei davanti sono siete contenti che ci
ho provato
avete visto che è impossibile avete
visto che io non posso staccarmi il
fegato e ridurlo in portiglia per
giocare sta merda
per me è minimo stoop lei può morire ci
ho provato il sommesso l'anima ci ho
messo il corpo ci ho messo anche
l'intestino spero che visto che sia
piaciuto ragazzi loro più episodio
grazie per gli infarti gratis che ho
preso non sono serviti a un cazzo di
niente perché siamo al punto di partenza
però altro giorno altri infarti altre
mutande da cambiare quello che vide vi
sia piaciuto ragazzi con la sensi video
è piaciuto un commento è un mi piace
anche a facili facebook come nei video
trattare descrizione assistiti si vede
ci vediamo al prossimo video dei ragazzi